混雑夏の思い出ほぼない
みなさん夏と言えば辛いものを食べたくなりませんかわかるよ冷たいものをアライブを
食べたくなるけどもあえて逆にこの課題ものを食べて汗をかくっていう楽しさもあるん
ですよというわけで私ここ1か月ぐらいで色んなお店に行く機会があるんですけども
いろんなお店で見つけたからそうなメンバー
4片っ端から集めてみました
はいちょっと見るだけでもなんか変男性をかけようなば経度している原そうなラーメン
屋貴様まあそうそうして麺類なんですけどもからそんな麺類を片っ端から集めてみまし
た
前の私根本的に辛いものが嫌いなんですけどもわかんないですが課題ものって美味しい
んですよ分かりませあっこれ叶え戻って美味しいんですおいし山を求めるがゆえに辛い
ところヶ月通過しなければいけない
つまりそのおいしい一定にたどり着けたらにからよの味はなきゃいけないということは
その美味しい1点を伏せてピアスわけですよこれから買う人ことによって一転してない
そのおいしいって体も12点に暮らしたんで華やかなそれを増えますよあれまだ冬ん
ですけどさぁ
12点というそのなるべく考案広かった天に向かって俺はかなりの梢がこっちまで
たどり着ければめちゃくちゃおいしい紹介
ができるのか何言ってんだろうねやっぱ要するに辛いもんっておいしいんですねこれは
正世とめちゃくちゃ辛いものができるんですけどもうそんな分美味しいものができるん
じゃないかというわけで今日はちょっと苦手なんですけどから事はないものを一変して
あげていこうと思いますでないか
本当に強いをちょっと紹介していきましょうまたこちら
レッドするがしたんだ目
うーん釣りこちら妊娠で飾った卓球目これから員とかなぁ
どんなからあー花絵巻陸奥俺が入ってますね一平ちゃん主に赤から豚ラーメン屋どう見
てもかないでしょ
ちょっと業が多いのでどんどん作っていきますそれでこちら赤いを西尾完全にから
イヤーにそれでパッケージだったことってあるんじゃねーよねでもかな
そうだなぁ随時こちらもう書いてるも寸劇1ターンする絶対くらいじゃ
混ぜていうかそもそも1ターンて竿にか入ってないってファンタントにくれよね俺無理
だ真ん中の麺だけ食べましょう
やばいは死んできたんで完全にからやってねコーラもうデータこの小さいお子様や辛い
のが苦手な方は十分ご注意下さいっていうこの猫はよ
続いてこちら金ちゃんヌードルのかな水こんなのあるんだねやイーヤーを包み緊張
ヌードルで
am
ああああで表示されるかもに通じこちらしてれた知っているめちゃくちゃ辛いラーメン
辛ラーメンでございまーすいなーでまずで辛い寄付します音がゆえに僕食べたことない
んですけどねコーネオヤないって危険だよな本局
ラーメンですこれは何かくそかないってことキレもあるんですよね
この人が作ってくれたんでしょうね服に書いてありは2代目中卒
まあマジでからそうだなあこっちの方向ラーメンだこっちは蒙古タンメン中卒
今日は本人です2分なぜ普通の途中息があるんだろうねこの蒙古タンメンと北極
ラーメンがめっちゃ課題て聞いたねここらへんが多分ポイントになっています
違うじゃーんなんではいいんだよまじ言ってはこれが以前から出たらからねほんとに
もってやばいな
んだけどこれも入れるにはスタイルというわけでゾーンに鑑定してきたのでまとめて
この中華ダレに入れて代表に辛いラーメンを作っていきました
一般作っていこうよどんどん入れてみましょうにゃんも連れて行かないや
こういうカラーもどんどん増えてきますね
色がやばいったらここでも出来ませんよちゃんと全部混ぜて胎教に辛いラーメンを作っ
ていきましょうね
う
ヒーローん血中で最後に混ぜてからこの院長
やばいよまたからそうだよそんなこれおもろいいろいろ
待って明日ベタが赤いいます
いやぁああああああ
高齢を過ぎるって自慢すイェーイ
うわぁ
[音楽]
ですねちなみに見てください作っているだけでこの当てです
2とプラー味いきます
ねええええ
うーんレッドストーン系マインクラフトの
地震舐めろと思って
それでお肉とかワンタンが食べれないのでそういうのはちょっと向かせていただいて
おります詳しいくださいそしてクズ北極ラーメン
入ってない待ってお前ますよねいいのかその焼きそば別に入れなくていい気がすんだ
けど
ないでっ
ねえぞ
ていた
[音楽]
たいという上でこれが午前ず俺が酷いって何目につけたからそうな麺類を全て
混ぜ合わせた子ゾウ最強に解体今日のラーメンでございますもういるだけでも汗が
止まらないくらいなら変なオーラを放ってるんですけども果たしてどれくらいの畔なる
のでしょうか
いただきますこのティック課題ですよめちゃくちゃ美味しいみたいな流れた通り嬉しい
な魚向き合っていろんな長さの
ガイル3なっておりますそれでしょでいただきます
すごい
うまいなんか最初の溝最初だけどね
[音楽]
んんあの叶えるラーメンが一番美味しいやつですね
うんまあ
うん発明しちょっとしてうまいんだよ
ねぇー
えっクリアせよ
[音楽]
待ってください辛いです動かしなさい背負う目のにな
やっぱだんだんさぁさぁを感じできません
持ってい
ブーブーああああ
うわぁ
ん
goo
人よりだブータブルワーズよね汗が止まらないんですよねだ本当にあのめっちゃ
美味しかったのは事実でございますまずで別だから唐津ギルドとなんか食堂
だから食堂がだんだん痛くなってくるのがちょっとね怖いなあと思ったんで
これがみんなで食べると思いますいやーかないダメ間なみなさんもよかったらぜひやっ
てみてください
じゃない